[Musik]
auch wenn die feierlichkeiten aufgrund
der korona krise in kleinerem rahmen
erfolgen findet auch dieses jahr wieder
der tag der miliz statt
diese wurde 2017 als wertschätzung den
milizsoldaten gegenüber eingeführt heuer
dient das deutschmeister denkmal in wien
als kulisse für den festakt der miliz
beauftragte generalmajor erwin hannes
eder zieht eine zwischenbilanz zum coup
einsatz und lobt die milizsoldaten für
ihren einsatz
die eingesetzten milizsoldaten und
milizsoldaten sind höchst diszipliniert
sind wirklich voll einsatzbereit einsatz
willig und bringen ihre kenntnisse und
fähigkeiten aus dem zivilen aber auch
aus dem militärischen so ein wie wir uns
das erhofft haben und ich weiß von
bundesminister auch du warst bis dato
fest unterwegs hast dich selbst vor ort
überzeugt und ich habe mir das auch
erlaubte nur dann wenn man mit den
kameradinnen und kameraden direkt
sprechen kann weiß man auch was wirklich
los ist doch egal wie kompetent und
engagiert die soldaten auch sein mögen
es braucht die notwendigen mittel
tatsache ist auch meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und das haben wir jetzt
auch gesehen und aus diesem einsatz
werden wir lernen dass wir auch die
materiellen ressourcen voll zur
verfügung stellen müssen und diese
defizite sind jetzt auf einem niveau
aufgetreten wo klar ableitbar ist für
die politischen verantwortungsträger
dass hier wirklich höchster
handlungsbedarf gegeben ist von einer
seite gibt es eine klare unterstützung
und ein klares bekenntnis für einer
deutlichen einer relevanten anhebung des
verteidigungsbudgets denn nur wenn es
das gelingt bleibt auch geld für die
ausstattung der miliz übrig
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
betont nochmals die notwendigkeit des
einsatzes und gesang
sich bei den milizsoldaten mit einer
besonderen wertschätzung wir haben uns
auch entschieden dass all diejenigen
wehrpflichtigen des miliz standes die am
vierten mai 2020 zur leistung des
einsatz präsenzdienstes einberufen
worden sind und diesen wehrdienst auch
tatsächlich angetreten haben eine
anerkennungsprämie bekommen sollen
das soll zumindest ein sichtbares
zeichen nach der wertschätzung für die
soldatischen dienste der miliz kräfte
sein
je höher dieser prämie kann bis zu 1000
euro betragen das hängt dann von der
jeweiligen individuellen entlassung aus
dem einsatz präsenzdienst
[Musik]